hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und willkommen zu diesem neuen
kochvideo in dem ich ein bisschen nee
hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und willkommen zu diesem
wirklich grandiosen Video und ich
erkläre euch jetzt wieso timo hat morgen
Geburtstag oh und die ist Geburtstag und
ich brauche natürlich für ihn ein
Geschenk und nach so vielen Jahren die
man zusammen ist es wirklich schwer noch
originelle Geschenke zu finden bzw Dinge
zu kaufen die der andere noch nicht
hatte bzw sich nicht selber kaufen
könnte was ich aber immer gerne schenke
sind gemeinsame Momente und Zeit die man
miteinander verbringen kann
ist übrigens ein guter Tipp falls ihr
für jemanden geraten geschenkt sucht
gemeinsame Zeit und weil wir ständig
beide überarbeitet sind machen wir
einfach zusammen einen kleinen Urlaub
nur wo soll die Reise hingehen wir waren
doch schon überall Südkorea New York
Mallorca wir haben quasi die Welt
gesehen wer jetzt mal ehrlich mir fällt
halt wirklich schwer mich dabei zu
entscheiden also habe ich mir eine
kleine Challenge überlegt ich lasse Timo
zum Orakel für sein eigenes Geschenk
werden das heißt ich koche drei Gerichte
aus drei verschiedenen Ländern und das
Gericht mit den meisten Punkten gewinnt
und da fahren wir hin
komm jetzt sagt's einfach das ist eine
richtig geile Idee und das Beste daran
ist Timo hat absolut keine Ahnung davon
ich habe also die letzten drei Tage für
ihn drei verschiedene Gerichte gekocht
Zusammenarbeit mit Hello fresh mit
HelloFresh kannst du jede Woche eine
neue kaufbox zusammenstellen und dabei
aus 34 verschiedenen Rezepten die
wöchentlich sich ändern immer neu wählen
dabei kannst du entscheiden ob du für
zwei bis vier Personen Koch und ob du
drei vier oder fünf Gerichte haben
möchtest kommen wir zu den Gerichten und
zu den Ländern wo es hingehen könnte
bitte bitte bitte Burger espanola also
nach Spanien um genauer zu sein nach
Barcelona Schupfnudeln mit Bacon und
Sauerkraut ins Schwabenland also nach
Hause zu seinen Eltern Tomate jähriger
Toni mit Rinderhackfleisch das ist
Italien Rom und wir starten mit Tag eins
Burger espanola mit pikantem Hähnchen
dazu pimentos der Patron in Paprika Soße
man bekommt HelloFresh per Post
geliefert und hat alles in einer Box und
wie habe ich das jetzt zubereitet ich
habe die häh muss Filets waagerecht
aufgeschnitten und wie ein Buch
aufgeklappt dann habe ich sie in eine
große Schüssel getan und mit einem
Esslöffel Öl dem hello Smokie Paprika
mariniert mit etwas Salz und Pfeffer
nachgewürzt in einer großen Pfanne ein
Esslöffel Öl auf hoher Hitze erhitzen
und Piment aus der Patronen darin 3 bis
4 Minuten scharf anbraten beiseite
stellen und mit Salz würzen in der
großen Pfanne habe ich dann erneut ein
Esslöffel Öl erhitzt die Hähnchenbrust
darin auf jeder Seite 1 bis 2 Minuten
scharf angebraten und dann die pikante
Paprikasoße dazu gegeben und weitere
drei bis vier Minuten gebraten
währenddessen habe ich eine zweite
Pfanne erhitzt die Burger Brötchen
aufgeschnitten und in der Pfanne mit der
Schnittfläche nach unten ein bis zwei
Minuten getoastet danach die
Salatblätter abwaschen und abzupfen
Burger Brötchen Hälften mit Aioli
bestreichen danach mit Salatblättern und
mit Hähnchenbrust belegen zum Schluss
noch die Piment aus der Patronen auf den
Teller legen und die restliche Paprika
Soße darüber garnieren und fertig und ob
es noch Barcelona geht entscheidet jetzt
nur noch Timos Gaumen bist
du ja es riecht fantastisch
zu bewerten bitte schön heute gibt es
Burger espanola mit pikanten Hähnchen
wow wow also optische war auf jeden Fall
eine zehn von zehn bin jetzt nicht so
der Fan von diesen Paprikas bin ich
ehrlich und der sieht aber hingegen
wieder fantastisch aus juicy oder
schönes Band
boah
krass lecker sehr sehr Lucy gar nicht
trocken und leicht taucht Tomate ein
bisschen scharf ungewohnt für den Burger
bin ich ehrlich schmeckt auf jeden Fall
anders aber richtig geil eigentlich gar
nicht ne
mh Fan davon
Gericht jetzt Punkte geben müsstest dass
der Patronen sind ein bisschen runter
also bekommen von mir eine sieben danke
vielen Dank
klassische Burger Geschmack sondern
einfach fresh viel frischer schmeckt
oder einfach ne ich liebe aber
[Applaus]
sieben von zehn Punkten ich hatte mir
mehr erhofft ich hatte Lust auf
Barcelona ich war noch nie dort und ich
hätte es gerne gesehen aber ich glaube
da geht noch mehr also machen wir weiter
mit Tag Nummer zwei ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher mit diesem Gericht ich
glaube es ist ein starker Anwärter aber
am Ende ist es Sauerkraut und so und
eigentlich eher so ein sehr
Hausmannskost essen was natürlich auch
zum Verhängnis werden kann wenn er dann
an seine Kindheit denkt
aber jetzt kommt erstmal Zubereitung
schupfnudelpfanne mit Bacon und
Sauerkraut dazu Kräuter Schmand das ist
ein Gericht das soll wieder Zeit sparen
family friendly sein und in 15 Minuten
fertig sein Okay zuerst die schupfnudel
Braten in einer großen Pfanne ein
Esslöffel Öl bei mittlerer Hitze
erwärmen Schupfnudeln und Bacon darin
fünf bis sieben Minuten anbraten
gelegentlich umrühren bis sie knusprig
und leicht gebräunt sind Petersilie und
Schnittlauch fein hacken in einer
kleinen Schüssel Schmand mit den
Kräutern verrühren mit Pfeffer und Salz
abschmecken weißen und grünen Teil der
Frühlingszwiebeln getrennt voneinander
in dünne Ringe schneiden Sauerkraut
Butter und weiße Frühlingszwiebelringe
zu den Schupfnudeln geben und 3 Minuten
weiter braten Schupfnudeln mit etwas
Piment und Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken
dann Schupfnudeln auf den Teller geben
und mit Grün Frühlingszwiebeln und dann
mit einem Klecks Kräuter Schmand
genießen und ob es in Timos Heimat geht
seht ihr wenn das Licht angeht
die Spannung steigt ich rieche es schon
ich erwarte also soll ich sagen was ich
raus riecht schon Sauerkraut bestimmt so
ein bisschen Kartoffelbrei irgendwas und
dann noch wahrscheinlich
Rosenkohl oder sowas Gericht doch
Schupfnudeln ja das ist jetzt wirklich
mal eins meiner absoluten favorite da
bin ich immer mit Weihnachtsmarkt das
wird jetzt ein Trip daunternehmer
danke schön
sind halt nicht knusprig aber es gibt
immer Pfanne mit der Bewertung
[Musik]
hat habe ich sofort gesehen wie gut in
das schmeckt das kann doch nicht sein
zehn von zehn für die Schupfnudeln mit
Sauerkraut und Bacon und auch Gericht
Nummer 3 und damit Italien vielleicht
noch nach vorne ziehen kann in diesem
Länder Battle seht ihr jetzt tomatige
Rigatoni mit Rinderhackfleisch getoppt
mit frischen Kräutern und Hartkäse das
ist auch ein family Gericht und Achtung
ein One pot-gericht und nun kommen wir
zu dieser wirklich einfachen Zubereitung
dieses one Pots Gericht one potsgericht
one pot-gericht ah Grammatik Oregano
Blätter fein hacken Zwiebel fein hacken
Knoblauchzehe abziehen in einem großen
Topf mit Deckel ein Esslöffel Öl bei
mittlerer Temperatur erhitzen
Rinderhackfleisch und gehacktes Zwiebeln
in einen Topf geben und eine
Knoblauchzehe dazu dabei das Hackfleisch
gut zerkleinern Topf in Gehalt mit
Kochsahne und 500 ml heißem Wasser
ablöschhühnerbrühe hello Harissa und
nach Geschmack Oregano dazugeben die
Rigatoni unterrühren aufkochen und
abgedeckt ca 11 bis 13 Minuten köcheln
lassen zwischendurch mehrmals umrühren
wichtiger Hinweis bei One Pot hier ne
besonders zum Schluss wenn das Wasser
weg ist dann muss man öfter umrühren
damit die Nudeln und alles da nicht
unten so anpackt wenn die Rigatoni
fertig gegart sind tomatenpesto
unterrühren die Hälfte vom geraspelten
Hartkäse hinzugeben und gut vermengen
bis der Käse geschmolzen ist mit Salz
und Pfeffer abschmecken die passt dann
nun in einem tiefen Teller anrichten mit
dem Hartkäse Torten und das Basilikum
drüber streuen ich dekoriere es auch mal
ganz gerne mit ein paar
Basilikum Blättern das ist einfach
unglaublich und ob die italienische
Küche hier den sieht noch nach Hause
holen konnte oder ob die Schupfnudeln
Timo nach Hause holen
das seht ihr jetzt beim offiziellen Timo
geschmacksorakel wir haben
hier regnet
alles in einem Topf ich bin so gespannt
wie du es findest
[Musik]
wie Nudeln mit Chili con Carne aber ohne
Tomate
dürfte ein bisschen salziger sein für
meinen Geschmack ja aber lecker geile
neue Taste experience auf jeden Fall
trägt von mir eine bessere meine zehn
von zehn ne über Nacht oder neun zehn
ist genau mein Ding ist genau mein Ding
ja
meine Schwiegereltern gucken jetzt
wahrscheinlich zu und es tut mir
wirklich sehr leid aber ich wäre sehr
gerne nach Rom oder Barcelona geflogen
ich war noch in keinem dieser Städte und
es wäre ein toller Kurztrip gewesen
warum habe ich Stuttgart da noch mit
reingepackt
timo hat noch keine Ahnung von seinem
Glück ich bin sehr gespannt was er zu
seinem Geschenk sagen wird ich gehe das
jetzt erstmal kaufen denn ja ich muss ja
noch nicht wo es hingeht aber davor
erzähle ich euch noch mal was über
HelloFresh ihr seht es gibt natürlich
eine Vielzahl an unterschiedlichsten
Gerichten ich habe meine Auswahl so
erstellt dass ich Städte und Länder habe
die wir bereisen können ich hätte
vielleicht auch Mexiko mit reinpacken
können einfach noch Mexiko geflogen wie
Ihr sehen konnte das alles portions
genau abgemessen und so wird es zu dir
nach Hause geliefert und das Ganze ist
total flexibel du kannst die Anzahl der
Gerichte ändern die Personenzahl du
kannst pausieren und kündigen und alles
ganz easy und mit dem Code hallo mal war
eine kannst du bis zu 90 € auf deine
ersten vier Boxen sparen wie viel du am
Ende Spaß hängt natürlich davon ab
welche Boxen bestellt mit wie vielen
Gerichten alle Infos dazu findet ihr
natürlich in der Infobox und da gibt's
auch den Link und da kommt ihr dann
direkt zu hello fresh und ich gehe jetzt
einkaufen
[Musik]
ich bin wieder da der Einkauf war
anstrengt aber erfolgreich ich habe die
beste Farbkombination an
geburtstagsgeschenkpapier
zusammengepackt ich habe einen Naruto
Puzzle gefunden das will ich ihm auch
unbedingt schenken das ist so cool
spätestens jetzt wisst ihr dass er Nerd
ist Herr der Ringe exit Game wir haben
mal so ein extra Game gespielt und das
war eigentlich ganz cool und das ist mit
der Herr der Ringe und wir lieben Herr
der Ringe und jetzt kommt sein
Hauptgewinn
er ist jetzt gerade beim Friseur
deswegen kann ich so laut reden nützt
ihr eigentlich diese Marco Polo
Reisebücher ich habe das noch nie
verwendet aber es gibt es ja mit jeder
Stadt und es ist eigentlich so praktisch
weil man einfach alle besten Hotspots so
auf einer Dings hat Leute oh wie cool
auch wenn es dich noch so reizt versucht
bloß nicht die schwäbische Mundart
nachzumachen du wirst sehen du kriegst
es sowieso nicht hin und gestandene
Stuttgarter fühlen sich zu Recht auf den
Schlips getreten ein hochdeutsches grüß
Gott kommt immer übrigens gut an
[Musik]
so wir haben dir deine Geschenke bis
jetzt gefallen
10 von 10 ist ein ungewohntes Szenario
ich habe mit meinem Leben noch nie einen
Geburtstag filmisch dokumentiert aber
bis jetzt war es auf jeden Fall erzählen
so und dieses Geschenk dafür darf man
sagen was du da geschrieben hast für
alle für ja also ich habe nämlich
mehrere Kategorien bekommen hier und das
auf jeden Fall für alle wir haben schon
die ganze Zeit überlegt was es sein
könnte aber ich komme nicht drauf
oh mein Gott
zuzuschreiben muss man an der Stelle
sagen zur Hölle Angst ist aufzumachen
was ist
Stuttgart du weißt doch dass ich dir
drei Gerichte gekocht habe du solltest
ja alle drei gerichtet werden und das
Gericht mit den meisten Punkten hat
gewonnen später
also wenn italienisch
oh mein Gott wie geil geil ich liebe die
kreativ das heißt ich bin einfach jetzt
an der Rum vorbei geschlittert und
leider direkt in den Kessel in meiner
Heimat rein Mama ich komme ich liebe
aber die Idee oh mein Gott ich liebe
voll schön
simpel zehn von zehn sagst du noch und
dann dachte ich mir schon so es ist
entschieden so geil oh mein Gott ich
liebe dich ich freue mich tatsächlich
sehr Stuttgart
Kartoffelsalat der Welt
fantastisch es war wunderbar
Ausflug Kamera
[Musik]
so Leute das war's mit dem Video ich
hoffe ihr hattet viel Spaß hier gibt's
das Auto und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste Mal wieder bis dann